all right good morning everyone wow you
all just sort of descend into the
distance which is actually kind of cool
I don't know if you can see it as well
this stage actually hangs on chains so
you can you can rock it which is really
good if you've been out too late last
night which is not me because I knew I
had to do this thing this is a really
different talk for me because it's it's
not about hacking sort of computer
things and physical things and I
normally do the you know like the sequel
injection and the Wi-Fi stuff which is
really good but this is one of these
sort of soft skills talks right more as
well so more about sort of the things
that that I've done to allow me to get
to where I am and you know like
literally where I am here in Norway and
be able to do the things I do today and
a lot of it's about the experiences I
had as I left the corporate world now I
was working for these guys I spent 14
years at Pfizer and for those you who
don't know what Pfizer is will your
lease not viagra is right no okay check
your junk mail it's in there now you
might sort of think about go and go well
you know like the office must have been
a lot of fun right of the whole time we
would have been proverbially flicking
the light switches but there's a whole
bunch of things that the sort of went on
that drove me to where I am now and one
of the I guess the first catalyst for
creating kind of an independent life and
to be clear as well this talk is not
about how to go out and be independence
about how to be happier and more
productive as developers how to do your
job better how to make your companies
happy as well and one of the things that
may inevitably occur as a result of that
is you get some more choices in life so
I start a blog and this was this was
almost eight years ago now and the very
first blog post that I wrote was this
one why online identities a smart career
moves and I sort of had this theory
these are sort of quotes from the
original blog post I thought look one of
the best things you can do to make
yourself more marketable is to have an
active online profile
and part of the reason that I was sort
of forming these conclusions is that I
was interviewing people in my old job
and that come along and they did a
normal interview evening that give you
you sit there their CV and everything on
the CV says I'm awesome look like course
you are you wrote it you're going to say
you're awesome and then they go no no
like don't speak to my references you
chose them of course we're going to say
that you're awesome you're going to pick
references to do that and we all do this
right this is how you market yourself
this is how you do see these and job
interviews and even when you look at
LinkedIn and you look at all the
endorsements and references and things
everyone's saying that you're awesome
because you build this profile of people
who have a vested interest perhaps
because they're friends of saying how
great you are
what I wanted to do is sort of be able
to more go towards the point of saying
that rather than just telling other
people that you're also what you do
let's show let's demonstrate and at the
time back in 2009 it wasn't that I was
looking to change my job I didn't want
to get out of there and go and do
something else I didn't want to work for
another company didn't want to be
independent but the theory I had at the
time is that at some point in the future
I might now that might be my choice
might be their choice and as it turned
out it took about five years before I
hated my job
and took about another year after that
before the job was gone and this will
sort of take you through how that
happened so I saw work out here and this
is it's a sort of a typical semi
industrial site out in Australia them
and I Drive out here each day and I'd go
to my office and I had an office just
there and it was in the basement it was
right down the bottom and it was in the
middle so it looked like this now I
didn't get to have windows windows a
privilege my bus had windows he was
never there I'm not quite sure why he
needed the windows but it was important
to reflect his stature by having an
office with windows and this was sort of
I guess it's like this two men
places right there is a perceived
hierarchy and as you go through this
hierarchy you've got to be able to
demonstrate that you have achieved this
level by having the fruits of that labor
so that the office with the window and
the car space with the number in the
roof and all this other sort of stuff
that frankly didn't rub me up the right
way so that was how it was and and to
fast forward to where it is now and then
we'll kind of talk about the journey I
have a lot more light in my current
office which is quite nice
my coworker to much nicer to some of
them some of them are actually much
better developers in the eldan and I go
here on my jet ski and I take my laptop
and then I go home and every time I go
home I'm enormous ly excited as I
arrived in the jet ski not only lot more
tanned when I'm in Australia but I do go
home on the jet ski and the thing about
the jet ski is that you never see anyone
on a jet ski who's unhappy right like
everyone is always smiling google it you
will not find unhappy personal jet ski
and when I go home I'll go down here and
this is this is where we live this is
our street there's enough at a Gold
Coast Australia Street and this is not a
fabricated photo till it looks like it's
out of a game but it's just like iPhone
here you go and then we go home to a
house and this is where we live now and
there's a little garage behind the jetty
there and there's a ramp comes down and
the jet ski goes on there in your Park
modeski and I'm showing this because I
want to try and show as I go through
this how significant a change occurred
because of the things that I'm going to
talk about and I didn't want to sort of
say go and do all this stuff and maybe
something nice will happen I wanted to
be quite clear about it but I'm also
really conscious that in Norway we have
this now I could read this to you but I
think most of you know what it means for
those of you who are not Norwegian and
are unfamiliar with this this is
actually Danish guy called upsource and
the most and he wrote back in the early
30s about jaunt 11 so Norwegians you
guys not gentle over news yeah alright
for non Norwegians
if he was Australian it'd be tall poppy
syndrome and basically the premise here
is is resentment of the success of
someone else and it's I guess it's being
conscious that when you you show
successful things and you show life
being good other people will potentially
resent that so I have to be very
conscious that as I go through this and
again I want to talk not just about
money sides of things as well but other
things that you can do to make your life
a lot happier and really a lot of this
comes down to the opportunities that you
want to make and I'm going to have a few
sort of quotes like this which I think
of kind of pertinent for all of us in
our careers especially those of us
working as developers as I was when I
talk about opportunities it's not just
about the money now obviously that's
something important inevitably that's
the reason many of us are working in the
first place right I'm sure if we could
choose to do whatever we want and the
money wasn't a factor we would probably
do different things so when there is
that opportunity that's important very
important to a lot of people how happy
you are with what you do is also
anonymously important there is some [ __ ]
jobs out there let's be honest and this
is almost sort of a metaphor I think for
the way many of us have probably felt in
our work lives particularly in our
corporate lives and having the choices
to be able to say maybe I want to go and
do something different maybe this isn't
the role for me and in terms of making
opportunities for yourself for many
people it comes back to family so do I
want to have more time with my family do
I want to have more flexibility do I
want to spend less time in the office so
all of these things that are different
motivators for different people and I
appreciate that everyone has different
things that are important to them at
different levels so where it really
started for me is what I mentioned
earlier on with the blog and I really
think that blogging was was just sort of
pivotal way to start getting exposure in
such a good platform because it's
something very very easy to start on and
it's something that you can build very
very
large and I actually think that if
anyone's considering there's talking to
your boss about blogging is a really
good thing and I want to sort of talk
about why this is such a productive way
of working so one of the things that I
found in a corporate environment is that
you're always working with people who
are a little bit of an echo chamber to
some degree so they've got the same
interest a lot of them are hired with
the same skill sets depending on where
you are you may even be much better at
some areas of technology than the other
people you work with Pfizer was
divesting a lot of its technical
resources and I was one of very few
people that were left so it was hard for
me to go and have discussions with
people about architecture or coding or
security or any of these sorts of things
and I'd find that that I would implement
something so I'd come up with an idea so
for example here's how we're going to do
source control and everyone go yeah
that's that's awesome okay are you
saying it's awesome because you really
understand it and you think it's awesome
or are you saying it's awesome because
you're being polite and that's the other
thing that happens in a corporate
environment everyone has a level of
politeness which you kind of need to
have right because you work with each
other when you write blog posts and you
put them on the internet a lot of people
aren't so polite I'm going to give you
some examples of that later but in a
more sort of constructive manner I guess
what I mean by that is that there are a
lot of people out there that are willing
to tell you when you're wrong or that is
a better way of doing it and when you
write about anything on the internet
chances are you're not going to be the
smartest person in the room there's
going to be a lot of other people that
understand this thing better than you
and have thought about it much longer
than you and that's definitely still the
case for me today as well so one of the
great things about writing and putting
it online is the amount of feedback that
you get that make what you're doing
better than if you just sat there in
isolation and this is one of the value
propositions for the boss as well right
I want to write a blog because I want to
get more information about how I'm doing
this the other thing I found is that
when I wrote blogs so for example this
one on the teamcity this was in 2010 I
wrote a five
part blog series and when I wrote this I
was actually rolling out teamcity
continuous integration in Pfizer I had
no idea what I was doing but I went and
researched it and wrote it down very
very precisely because I wanted to get
all my facts right because if I didn't
get them right there would be someone on
the internet telling me I was an idiot
and I don't like getting feedback like
that so I wrote it out very very
carefully five part series and I got
wonderful feedback from people lots of
people said hey this is awesome this is
really useful and you can still go to
this day and read this series and read
all the comments that actually
contributed through that post a lot of
the gold in these posts is often from
other people now this also served
multiple purposes because as I was
writing this out and trying to get all
of my facts straight and understand it
to a depth that I never would have done
if it was just me doing it for Pfizer I
was also creating documentation and when
I left the organization eventually and
people said where's the documentation
for teamcity
it's like WWE hunt for flash and this is
how I built it and configured it there
are a few other internal things
obviously but that was the main part I
had lots of experiences like this so
things like PowerShell and as you're an
automation and we're moving a lot of
things from traditional hosting into
Azure and what I started to do is to use
the time I had in the office to write
about stuff like this now I felt no
conflict of interest because I was
sitting there in the office trying to
figure out how do I explain this to
other people how do I get on my facts
right how do I get this spot on and when
I was doing that by writing on a blog
post again I was held to higher account
than what I ever would be if I just did
it internally now blog posts like this
are my reference as well so I go back to
this now when I need to remember how to
do it I literally Google Troy hunt is
your PowerShell and I go back to my own
blog post so I can remember what I was
doing there the great thing about
working like this is that it also gives
you enormous amounts of leverage and
what I mean by that is it rather than me
is sitting there in isolation doing my
job in Pfizer and impacting this one
organization those people around me when
I write blog posts like those there's
people everywhere that get use out of it
and not only that but it builds my
profile and I become known as the guy
that did the teamcity thing and now
there's a lot of references out there to
troy hunt and continuous integration or
troy hunt doing the is your thing so
I've used that one piece of time not
just to do my job and do it much better
than what I would have otherwise but to
also build my individual presence and my
individual brand and I was thinking if
someone else later on comes along and
says I want a higher try and I go out
there with a CV which says I'm awesome
and references that say I'm awesome they
can go and read stuff like that and see
what I was actually doing not just me
telling them now if you want to start
blogging you can get into something like
ghost and ghost is a really great
blogging platform I ran on blogger for
years Google blogger and basically they
just didn't change the platform they
didn't evolve and I moved to ghost
earlier last year and you can go and get
that either for free and then run it on
your own VPS stand up on a juror or
something like that or you can go and
run it on their hosted platform 62 cents
a day 19 bucks a month and I would
recommend doing this a lot of people
sort of go and I want to control it
myself want to run it online environment
I want to be a server admin you got to
decide like do you want to be server
admin or do you want to write blogs so I
highly recommend this the other thing is
going at cloud player and you can wrap
CloudFlare around your ghost blog and
you can get HTTP because you get the
padlock apparently the padlock is
important these days so you get that and
you get a globally distributed CDN and a
whole bunch of other nifty things and
the best bit about that one is free so
these are really good starting points
and the other thing that I'd add to that
is going get a template so there's all
these ghosts templates out there some of
them are free some of them are ten or
twenty bucks go and get that install it
and it's not going to be perfect than it
doesn't matter all that matters is that
you can get started you can start
writing stuff start creating things and
then you might go okay well what am I
going to write like I don't know where
do I start and to be honest it kind of
doesn't matter so long as you do
something so long as you start somewhere
so you saw the first blog post over
wrote earlier the second one is around
subversion so this was what we used to
do for source control before everyone to
get examples of Visual Studio 2010 net
four I was just pulling stuff
consolidating things from various places
I saw an again let's just put in one
place where I think it's interesting
I wouldn't recommend this one on
retrospect this has many other legacy
dependencies you have to deal with for a
long time but I was writing okay I was
putting stuff down and I was finding my
way finding out what I wanted to do and
I went out and did a lot more of this
sort of stuff this was the first time I
did any sort of Smackdown of a company
and believe me I was kind of nervous
after I put it out there because I
basically when Virgin Blue is doing a
bunch of [ __ ] stuff I hope I don't get
into trouble from version blue or my
boss but I don't know that my boss was
actually reading my blog post so as I
went along I was just putting stuff out
there the PDC conference professional
Developers Conference back in 2009 and
again like Visual Studio this was just
let's get a bunch of things together in
one place I rebuilt my home office this
was basically just buying computer
screens and a couple of other things
that many of you already do but when I
started to write about this stuff I
started to get an audience I started to
get comfortable with the blogging and
the interesting thing is that none of
this about security right like none of
these blog posts here or the first one
has got anything to do with security and
it kind of took me a while doing this
before I started to drift in that
direction so the real point here is not
to sort of feel that you have to have a
goal or an itch to begin with you just
begin and then things evolve
now beyond blogging you can write in
many other places as well so I was
writing on Red Gate simple talk for
quite a bit this is free you don't make
any money from this if this was around
ci-4 databases shared development
databases and again none of this has got
anything at all to do its security but
this was increasing exposure figuring
out what I liked what I enjoyed now some
you might then say okay well what if the
boss comes along the boss a bit worried
okay because the boss is thinking is
this going to be a problem now if you
work with the boss like this first of
all if your boss is concerned about you
getting too good at what you do
now whether that be because you do
blogging or whether it's because you go
into extra training or you invest your
personal time and let's be clear the
vast majority of effort that went into
this blog is still personal time if this
is where you are that is probably a sign
that it's not a very healthy environment
so you really need to think seriously
about that now that was blogging and
inevitably that the next thing that came
along was for speaking and this is the
first ever talk ever did I manage to
find online the other day and I did this
for SSW in Australia some of you might
know Adam Cogan he's here this week as
well he runs SSW and he asked me along
to do this user group talk and this was
in 2012 early 2012 and I look back at it
now and it's it's what you would expect
to see of your first talk when you
hadn't really practice much and you're
kind of figuring it all out but it was a
starting point and that kind of led
through eventually to things like the
opening keynote here last year but I
only got to do that because I did these
tiny little things that previous slide
was walking distance from my house this
event is like 30 hours on airplanes and
airports now so this is sort of the big
stage but they build up to it and the
speaking is enormous ly valuable because
it starts to certainly initially put you
out of your comfort zone you know a lot
of speakers get very nervous about doing
this there's a lot of preparation and
consternation and everyone's stressed
about what's going to happen but it
really really makes you focus on what
you're doing and of course it's it's
great exposure
us that's why myself and all the other
speakers are here this week as well it's
it's great exposure in terms of other
people seeing who you are but it's great
exposure to other people too and you
know I hope everyone's getting that out
of this week we are meeting people and
making connections and all of that is
really useful for your job so again
putting it back to this isn't just about
leaving your place of work you're here
because many of the things that you see
here and the connections you make will
help you do your job better now if you
want to get involved in speaking there
are a lot of calls for papers so for
example you could speak at MBC London in
January call for paper for that is open
right now you can go over there and say
hey I got a good idea I'd like to talk
about a thing it might be a data-based
thing or a web thing might be a soft
skills thing might be something totally
different you can go and submit that
call for paper you just need a title and
an abstract couple of paragraphs and
explain why I think it's awesome and you
may well get in probably about six
months from the other their call for
paper for NDC 2018 and particularly for
those of you who are local you have an
advantage because conferences like NDC
they do want to have a lot of local
representation so if you're thinking
about this you've got about six months
before you got to come up with a good
idea and then submit it for NDC 2018 now
the other thing that I still do a lot of
is I do a lot of user groups and just to
be clear things like user groups and
talks like this we don't make any money
from this there's no speakers getting
paid to come and go to the other side of
the world and stand on stage all of this
is the connections in the exposure the
user groups are really good because
there's so many of them and this was a
user group I did in Denmark earlier this
year and I normally sort of talk for
about an hour so to be a talk like
there's probably a little bit more
casual and then you sit around us or
we'll answer questions for an hour and
meet people and chat and these are
awesome and there are lots of user
groups wherever you are I know there's
lots of user groups in Norway because
I've done two of them already and some
of the other speakers have done other
ones so there's lots of places you can
go and say look I'd like to maybe go
along and have a look at what you're
doing and then I'd like to speak and the
barrier to entry is very very low if
you've got a good eye
here fantastic because everyone's going
on there for free and it's relaxed a bit
of fun so user groups are really useful
if you want to get speaking without
perhaps the stage presence in the stage
fright and everything that comes along
with it everything you have podcasts as
well certainly knows these guys right
great so these guys but certainly the
experts when it comes to podcast there
are a lot of other podcasts out there a
lot of places you can go and speak
without having to turn up on a stage so
for example sli's Clint's now I asked
Lars beforehand Lars is here in the
audience I said can I put this up here
and if anyone has got something that
they'd like to talk about on the podcast
can they come and talk to you and he
said yes so if you've got an idea or
something that you'd like to start
getting out there go and grab Lars we'll
go and grab man or pointed lives because
this is cool this gets you speaking and
it gets you exposure and it's in a
really stress-free kind of way so then
and pain Lars who's got a sec Overflow
counts in an audience like this you'd
like you know it's going to be a lot
Stack Overflow is great because Stack
Overflow becomes like a living breathing
history of what you've been doing and if
I'm honest I haven't spent a lot of time
on it in recent years but there was a
period there I went let's just spend a
heap of time answering questions and I'm
going to do that to build up my
expertise in this area because when I
have to think about I get a bit better
and it also means that someone can go
along to this page and go ok well what's
Troy been up to so not only here are the
questions that Troy's been answering and
the things that he obviously understands
but here the questions have been asking
and this is one of the things that
always sort of struck me in interviews
I'd say too that the candidates you know
like you get you get stuck on something
what do you do and really most of them
would just blow a heap of time on Google
searching for stuff and they were always
sort of reticent to go out there and put
questions out there online because when
you do this you're telling people what
you don't know and people are worried
about that but it's a great record or
it's a great record of saying look I've
been involved in these things and I'm
comfortable enough to say there are
things I don't know and you can go to my
profile
and see all the things I didn't know now
sometimes there are also no answers as
well and there's quite a few of those
where people just so hard work maybe
there's not a way to do that but it's
great and you can see up the top right
there the impact 861 thousand people
reached now I've only got thirty and a
half thousand odd reputation it's
probably a lot of people in this room a
bit more but there's 861 thousand people
that I've been able to reach even if
it's just a little bit and then when
they see that in conjunction with things
like the blog and the speaking it kind
of starts to build your image and your
reputation doing projects as another one
so there's there's a lot of ways of
getting involved in writing software and
I'm talking about writing software
independently of your career and for the
betterment of society and for public use
so this was a project that I built back
in 2011 automated security analyzed the
phrase piddle net websites and this was
if anything this is probably a really
good example of the leverage because I
was at Pfizer we're building websites on
asp.net and we'd be putting these
websites out there and every single time
we did this I'd be going okay if you
turned on custom errors do have your
traces exposed right your elmire logs
out there and I'll be doing all this
manually and I went okay well I'm going
to build a project to do this and it's a
simple project but it's very effective
and it actually saved me quite a bit of
time in the office right most of it at
home in my own time because I just
wanted to do it's kind of fun but it
saved me time in the office saved a lot
of other people time in other places
because they started using it and it
built my reputation as that asp.net
security guy so again it's the leverage
right like I did this once and it had
multiple uses over and over and over
again you learn a lot more when you
start to do projects that are publicly
facing to and if you don't do your own
project get involved in one of the
gazillions of open-source projects that
are out there even in just a little way
so I went from that under this and I
think many people probably now know this
one and this again was a great example
of the leverage where I did this one
thing but I used it
over and over again so what a lot of
people don't know is that the main
reason I built have I been poned was not
to search for data breaches but it was
to play with is Europe I wanted to play
with the new shiny checker I wanted to
play table storage and app services and
all these sorts of things and I'm
looking around going what am I going to
do I hear that data bridge thing that'll
do you know maybe people will like that
or do that and it became massive but the
great thing about that is that it meant
that not only did I get these your
experience which I took back in the
Pfizer and used to do the sorts of
things we were doing there I mentioned
we're moving a lot of websites so I was
really useful for that but of course
it's helped a lot of people and it's
gotten huge amounts of press as well and
the press has then helped me build my
identity and build my independence so
this is just sort of another one of
these things where by doing this once
and using it in many many different ways
it actually looks like I do a lot more
than what I do and often people again
like how do you do all this stuff that's
what you're actually looking at the same
thing multiple times over I've just
leveraged it now inevitably when you do
put things out there online I'm sure you
probably know this but some people on
the internet addicts let me give you
some examples now I mean let's be fair
about this some of them addicts and some
of them just simply have different views
different cultural perspectives and
we're going to look at a bit of both of
these but we might even just start with
with the cultural thing and a good
example of that is there's this little
video and if you saw me talk yesterday
afternoon you would have seen this video
it's only a few seconds but on a shout
to you again and then talk about some
feedback ahead you may not know it but
you've probably already been asked
thousands of hacking attack
each day now the reason I show this is
that it's a guy in a hoodie on a green
screen basically personifying every
stereotype people have about hackers and
it's promoting a product by using a
freely available website called hacker
typer hacker typer net suppose of you
haven't seen it you go there you match
the keyboard green text appears on the
screen oh so scary you hackers and I
show this because it's kind of hilarious
and I've shown this all over the world
I've probably done this talk where I
have this video maybe 20 times and when
I say all over the world predominantly
Europe and Australia but I did it in
Australia in Brisbane in December and a
guy came up to me after I did the talk
and he said this is something about your
talk and I was like cool you know how
was it and he liked it which is great
you know and the guy was American and he
was obviously traveling there from
somewhere else in the other side of the
world and he said the hacker you just
showed hello okay and he was kind of
hesitating a little bit and I've gone
what have I done and he goes he's black
it's like [ __ ] was he I didn't realize I
feel like I just got the video and I put
it in the video and then I looked at the
talk afterwards and the other hacker was
white and that hacker was white and that
hacker was white and I don't know that
one was because he had a mask and that
one was a bear but but what the guy his
perspective was coming from America
there is there is the negative
connotation of if you associate race and
crime yeah things like this can be
poorly received and this is not
something that that that happens in
Australia in terms of at least the
strength of that perception and I
haven't seen it anywhere else as well
but I after he said it as a whole year
the u.s. you know like I hadn't really
thought about that and this is the
reality when you put stuff out there
that faces the world you end up spanning
all of these different cultures and
you're going to piss some people off
and I was seen this sort of over and
over again in different contexts so I
did this blog post a few years ago now
which was about doing password resets
and what I was trying to say within this
blog post and it's one of my usual multi
thousand word posts cause I wanted to be
detailed as I said look when you do a
password reset it's really important not
to confirm whether the email address
exists on the site or not because this
is an enumeration risk it can tell other
people whether someone has an account
there and particularly on certain sites
like this one that's a bad thing
and I had to crop a lot of images out of
this screen cap in order to get it to
the point where I thought it was
suitable to put on my blog and I
eventually sort of distilled it down to
the point where I went okay there are
three girls this is Beach style clothing
it's you know no nudity per se this will
be fine and of course inevitably I had
feedback from a couple of people again
from mostly from the US because I think
they're a little bit more culturally
sensitive in parts they're Europe tends
to be a lot more progressive in that way
and they kind of said yeah look if my
boss walks past I'm going to get in
trouble and I was like look if your boss
walks past they're going to see flow
diagrams and walls and walls of text and
one little image but don't worry about I
haven't thought about it so I ended up
putting some text further up in a big
red box I said look as you scroll down
there's going to be a screen cap of an
adult website there is nothing that you
wouldn't see on the beach just in case
that would inconvenience you click here
and the image will be replaced by fluffy
bunnies the fluffy bunnies are not
wearing any clothes exactly what I said
because I was just a little pissed about
it I think what I was pissed about is I
put all of this effort into building
this big thing
many of these blog posts can take days
to write and I write them over a period
of weeks or month so when someone comes
and picks on something like that yeah it
is frustrating another one recently
wrote about cloud Slayer this is just
last year and yeah this to me was a very
important blog post and I had one sent
in there which was this one and as you
read that now you can sort of see how
maybe maybe some people from some
corners of one country in the world
might think maybe not so good and I had
a bit of feedback to that effect and you
know they'll Celsius one again I sort of
pissed that there's all this sort of
love and tender care going into a blog
post and a thing that they wanted to
talk about is how it made one offhanded
political statement like that was the
thing that they remembered out of all
this other good effort someone else left
a comment as well which which kind of
struck me because it's saying you know
like you could lose your reputation from
one sentence that was a fairly benign at
least in my mind comment about politics
you know subscribers could drop off and
then he said a small part of me died
today looks like [ __ ] you really really
like Trump there and then it kind of
went well so what you know like so what
if he's upset
do I have to please everybody all the
time if someone gets offended
does it matter too much and it's not
that you want to go around doing
terrible things that we collectively
would agree our offensive as a society
but if there's one or two people does it
matter and I found this great clip this
is an Aussie comedian called Steve
Hughes talking about being offended and
political correctness the oppression of
our intellectual movement so no one says
anything anymore in case somebody else
gets offended
what happens if you see that when
someone gets offended well they can be
offended wrong with being offended when
did sticks and stones may break my bones
stop being relevant know what to teach
children for God's sake that's what you
teach toddlers he called me an idiot
don't worry about him he's a dick they
have adults who have offended I was
offended and I have rights
so what we offended nothing happens
you're adults grow up deal with it
doesn't offended I don't care nothing
happens when you're offended is very
high I went to the comedy show and the
comedian said something about the Lord
and I was offended and when I woke up in
the morning I had leprosy because it's
true right like nothing happens and the
reality of it is and this is sort of the
thing that you need to get to grips with
is that you need to offend some people
because if you try so hard not to offend
anyone you're going to lose all of your
personality it's going to become so
bland so boring and there's just no
possible way particularly on the
Internet where some people just about
have a job of being offended it's just
impossible to put stuff out there and
not piss some people off but it's
confronting right particularly when
people get offended enough to start
doing stuff like this so this is a
disgust account dedicated to how much I
suck behind that you can see a wordpress
site that's Troy hunt sucks up
wordpress.com someone actually made a
blog dedicated to how much I suck and
they wrote many blog posts and
unfortunately they're no longer
available and I couldn't even find on
archive that org and I know it's weird
me saying I'm upset I can't find the
things with people getting offended and
angry at me but some of them were
hilarious I do have other though I'm
going to show you so this person devoted
time to doing this and I thought [ __ ]
there could be people out there who
really do think I suck I need to go and
register Troy hunt sucks calm and clear
things up and this is real this exists
you can go there now and you can see
very clearly I don't
now I talked about leverage right like
using things over and over again and I
was conscious that every time I register
a domain without paying for who is
privacy some our contact details are on
there
I don't ask this happens here as well
but I start getting calls from India
trying to sell me web development
services which is always a funny
conversation but I thought okay I'll do
this and then I'll see how many times I
can make them say Troy Hunt sucks
Troy and sucks [ __ ] they are all by Troy
and HUL the answer as you think it is
dot-com Troy on socks double or white
try then hunt hu every hunter as you see
KS done yes
you think it is well we are all I trust
hu NT er can certainly throw ours and
then such as juicy K F sake
now look this is endless entertainment
trust me and I would happily just go and
register the weirdest domains to get
calls like that from people that are
very very close to scammers trying to
sell me stuff I don't need but all of
this abuse is kind of in a way it's a
little bit benign it's a little bit
childish but there are times when it
does get serious and it does get does
get pretty direct and this kind of
brings us to a bit of a crossroads who
wants to see the censored version who
wants to see the uncensored version it's
just as well cuz that's all good all
right so sometimes people get very
direct and I thought I'll show you one
piece of feedback and this is normally
what the years I've been showing friends
as we drink beer and we laugh because
well well just read it
it's like we all need beers right now
just just to read and enjoy the glory of
this and of course the irony of it is
I'm here on the other side of the world
in front of hundreds of people showing
my useless face at another conference so
obviously I didn't take it particularly
seriously and to be fair like this is
one level of abuse and there is other
abuse out there particularly directed at
women in this industry which is just
unfathomably worse than this but imagine
how you feel when you do get stuff like
that you know and this I won't go into
the details but this was triggered off
by something very very benign and
someone obviously got to be and their
bonnet about it got very upset and you
do have to prepare that that as you sort
of go along and you build more momentum
and you're exposed to more people that
sort of tiny percentage of people ends
up being a larger individual number and
you get stuff like this but I don't want
that to sort of make some things seem
negative either because I have a huge
number of positive experiences online
and particularly things like social
media have been enormous ly valuable and
I do a lot through Twitter that's sort
of the the Avenue which I send you get
the most engagement from and as much as
I get some bad abuse like the other one
that is so exceptional and the norm is
more stuff like this and these are all
people that I've met virtually on
Twitter and then gone to events and met
in person and it still strikes me as a
weird thing when people come out in the
car can I get a selfie okay with me yes
look and what I love about this is
everyone there looks so happy and it's
not just them but I look happy too
because this is fun enjoy doing this and
sometimes when I go to somewhere new
I'll just tweet out you know something
random hey I'm going to be in a place no
do you want to go in get a coffee and
initially I was like are people going to
be like weird stalkers or you know like
who makes we're going to meet here but
it's always gone really really well and
this was in Belgium earlier this year
and I met this guy down here whoa called
Stein and he said then I'll show you
around at work which was nice and he
brought me
world's best beer which was very nice
and he sort of gives this to me he goes
here's world's best beer so everyone
says that about their beer but I looked
it up and it was it's the world's best
beer apparently with flatterin is even
better now because he gave me two of the
world's best beer of which one remains
but this was like just a chance
encounter you are literally on the train
how and going around words anyone I
catch up so the social media side of
things as much as people say it's
virtual it's not real it's online it
leads to engagements like this and it
leads to people that are interesting
connections and thinking about bringing
that back to your workplace in your
career as well this is really useful to
be able to meet all of these people in
the industry and to have people you can
call on and what I always tried to tell
people in Pfizer I don't think a lot of
people got this is that those
connections and those ability to reach
out to people is enormous ly valuable
you pay a lot of money to consultants
and companies to be able to talk to the
sorts of people you can just meet online
for free now inevitably while you're
online you're going to find that you can
also be polarizing we've established how
not everyone is going to be happy all
the time and recently we got a new car
and I posted a little video clip is a
little sound of the engine because it
sounds epic
and I've posted this online and
someone's come back with this and as
best I could tell what they were wanting
me to do is to tailor my Twitter feed
not to the 73 thousand other followers
but to then and I can't we just keep it
exclusively on security and again like I
see this and I get frustrated but by the
same token someone else pops up and goes
well this is what I like to hear you're
always going to find this polarizing set
of views but there's an interesting
thing that happens on Twitter which is
that it gives you other opportunities to
demonstrate who you are and I'll give
you an example that I recently got a new
machine from the Nova yoga 910 and I was
curious so I went home and I plugged in
the network I thought okay brand new
machine how much stuff is going to
download this is just like a geeky
interest
thing and then I put our tweet so I
plugged it in and it pulled down 12
gigabytes worth of data and I had a
screen cap showing that the sessions on
my local network that it used and I said
stats IU BNC there's ubiquity I put a
bunch of ubiquity stuff in my house
recently wrote a few blog posts about it
and I thought I better actually show
where these stats come from because
every time I show something like this no
don't explain it I get a heap of replies
and they go where's it strong and this
person got quite upset about that I'm so
gone okay
thrown down my Twitter feed it's like
three words you know like what are you
upset about and I was kind of pissed
about this and I was very tempted to
sort of go back and go mate you're a
[ __ ] you know like get real
butterfly you let's try something
different and I said this and just so he
knew that I wasn't trying to take the
piss out of him and I wasn't trying to
make a joke for the smiley face it was
fun but here's what happened after that
and this was really cool and this person
does still follow me today I checked
before I came and did the talk and it
just kind of made me think that there
are all these points where you have
these opportunities for conflict and
there's like this crossroads right and
you can go down this one path and say
make you know you're a dick it's my
Twitter time Island put whatever I want
piss off or you can do something like
this and now think about what this means
in terms of building your exposure
because if someone comes along and reads
your profile later on they get to see
stuff like that have you ever read
through someone's profile on Twitter or
Facebook you might have seen them being
a bit Ranchi or something then you read
through their timeline and you kind of
form this opinion of who the person is
and what they stand for and sometimes
it's a very negative opinion because you
see the way they're behaving but it can
go the other way as well so you can
create these positive impressions of
what you do and this is not a
fabrication right it's not like you're
trying to be fake it's being conscious
that you have this opportunity to
demonstrate your character which is kind
of cool
so I guess starting to sort of move back
towards the Pfizer side of things you
know I've been doing all of the things
that we just spoke about here and as
time went by they got very much into
this space outsourcing and I suspect
many of you have sort of been through
this in your companies because you're in
a part of the world that's expensive and
you're in an industry which is often
outsourced to other company but where
were we other countries and that the
rationale that that sizer had was pretty
much when okay we got these guys like we
have got people in sales and marketing
and they make the money since I think
some of you see where I'm going here
okay so making money these guys are
great but then we got these guys people
like you and I we cut money we are in
expense and I don't have to ask for show
hands because I know many of you again
here you know I feel this because this
is what happens in our industry often
technology is seen as a cost and I was
seeing this more and more I was seeing
this from the divestiture of technical
people contracts weren't renewed there
are a number of redundancies people
going and I'd see it every day in the
way people were treated as well so
perfect examples salespeople that's
where they'd go for sales conference
well it's nice right I'd be happy to go
there for a holiday let alone for a work
event
there's Hamilton Island up and Great
Barrier Reef in Australia the technology
people we went to local balls club down
the road but we did have a budget of $20
a head for the Christmas party
now that doesn't buy much more beer in
Australia than what it would in Norway
but it doesn't go very far and this was
the way technology was being valued then
in 2014 I've got a new boss and this
boss was in the Philippines so you're
always going to have a bit of a cultural
divide and particularly a lot of Asian
cultures are very hierarchical they also
have communication it's very they call
it very high context very implicit
whereas in Australia we're much more I
guess we're much more straightforward
we're much more
direct and I think most of Europe is
like this as well so as always going to
be a bit of cultural conflict but I've
got this new boss and before I started
reporting trying to look on going over
New Zealand in April to talk about code
mania I'm going to the code mania
conference then I going to talk there
and then I'm going to have a holiday
with my wife because we've been working
hard want a bit of a break yeah okay so
fun and then at one point he said
actually won't you come to the
Philippines in so well you know I can't
because I'm going here and then he said
now I'd really really like you to so
yeah but you know I card because I've
made commitments people have bought
tickets to this event in part because
they know that I'm going to be there I'm
going to speak and yeah I'm not going to
let people down plus I kind of want to
have a holiday with my life so he
replied and his exact words were other
priorities the company and you sort of
get to that point okay well your
objectives are clearly not aligned with
my objectives and all of the work that
the company like Pfizer puts into
talking about work-life balance or blend
or whatever it is recognition that
people have got to be happy in their
jobs just goes out the window when you
say something like that and I was just
getting to the point there in April 2014
where every time I went to work it was
feeling like this
so really all could spot the paws on as
well but it's like this will probably
resonate with many people and hopefully
this was not your job now maybe it's
been a job in the past where you've gone
there and every day it has just felt
like being kicked in the nuts and that's
what it was beginning to feel like and
okay we'll look you know I've got to get
out of this place I got to make a change
so what I started doing I'd already been
doing the blogging in the speaking
everything in degrees and I just ramped
it up to 11 so saying yes to absolutely
everything and I vividly recall being in
the office having this image in my mind
this is Jim Carrey from yes man so you
haven't seen the movie
it's where he just says yes to
everything even the craziest stuff and
all of these wonderful things happen so
people going can you go here and do a
webcast yeah all this is free right yes
I can do that can you go and speak there
yes order that this user group this blog
post this guest blog post and I was
going yes to everything and just working
non-stop so nights weekends everything
on the basis of what had already done so
I had a platform by the time my job but
very unhappy and of course one of the
things I was doing a lot of us was poor
site and I was writing a lot of courses
I'd written several already I decided
that in 2012 but when I started ramping
it up and building a lot more stuff by
the time I got to September that year so
this was only just after April 5 months
later it was actually making more money
than further and this is great you can
go online and build courses and if you
get enough people watching them you can
make more money than going into work and
feeling like you're getting hit in the
nuts all day so this was great and it
sort of then led my wife Kylie and I to
this discussion at ok well can we go can
we leave the company and the problem
here is you going yeah I can but then
like half my income goes you know
because it's like we could go back to
where we were before financially which
is great but you kind of so we talked it
over and we're talking it over late 2014
very early 2015 and I went back into the
office I had a meeting request
updates here we get one of these in the
eyelets it's curious and you look at the
attendee listing us it's an interesting
set of people to have in one meeting and
I go to the meeting and the the most
senior person in the technology
department there was a lady and she was
crying
it's more interesting and we're in a
conference room and my boss who's in the
Philippines at the time is on on the
phone and they go so here's the old chat
now and there's names
here's the old chat in the future and
there's no names and there's less boxes
and if there's people in the room and
there's bits of [ __ ] and there are
people that were very very worried
because for them when this was happening
it was going to be a very negative thing
on their lives they weren't ready
weren't prepared for something like this
to happen and of course the inevitable
did happen sorry to have to bring him
out again come to pub come tonight I
will fix everything but it was better
than being fired there are four of us
that were given redundancies and the
beautiful thing about a redundancy is
rather than being fired and basically
you just get booted out with very little
or leaving and you leave with very
little when you get a redundancy they
have to pay so everyone was sort of
getting very sort of stressed and
worried about it and thinking what is
going to happen to my life and I'm going
well you know now that I think about it
maybe not so bad
and pfizer to their credit had very very
good redundancy packages if you'd been
there long enough and I had been there a
long time and I walked out with almost a
couple of years worth of pay as opposed
to if I had left a bit earlier and I
just would have walked out with just
about nothing but of course all the
opportunities to Pluralsight in the rest
of it so it was early 2015 and by April
when I left I've been doing a lot more
Pluralsight courses and that was here
twice as much as my normal job and
suddenly it's only a third of my income
that I leave behind and I get all the
redundant
package so I was anonymously happy and I
left in April went out and got some
really nice champagne I don't remember a
lot after that I have photos I look
happy but I laughing right I'll stay and
the really important thing here is that
all the bits that I've done in the talk
up until now you know the blogging and
the speaking and everything else it made
me a lot happier whilst I was there but
it also meant that when I no longer
wanted to be there or more specifically
when no longer wanted me there I had
these choices in life so now it's very
different because I'm in places like
this and I travel around and do a lot of
these talks and workshops and things and
it often means that I'm in places like
this this is Copenhagen and I was there
in October and it's a typical European
autumn weather it's my son's birthday
and he's a home on them on the other
side of the world and this is how we
spend his birthday so I'm you know
literally facetiming with him and it
kind of makes you think about this other
thing as well and this applies no matter
how much effort you want to put above
and beyond your normal job which is that
you're putting a price on your family
and a lot of people feel really
uncomfortable when I say this to them
like what price do you want to put on
your family because they're like
family's priceless I can't put a price
on them but you're all here you know
what your family is and next week you'll
probably all go into the office and do
your office jobs we'll do whatever it is
you do for work as opposed to spend time
with your family so we all do this every
single day we make choices about what we
prioritize when and that the trick then
is to find the right balance so for me
it means being on the other side of the
world doing stuff like this but then
when I go home I've got all this
flexibility so I'll be down there at the
tennis court with my seven-year-old and
we'll play tennis and then I'll take him
to school and we'll have this quality
time together and then I'll pick him up
but whenever he finishes 3:30 in the
afternoon I don't have to be in an
office or the flexibility but the price
of justifying that is not just the
travel but it's the late nights and the
fact that I really don't know when
holidays start and
I must I'm not sure when weekends start
and finish because it just becomes like
a continuous blur and the thing is if
whether you do it to the degree which
I'm doing now the degree which I did
eight years ago and I started doing it
you're always going to be taking some of
your personal time to do this there's
always going to be something above and
beyond your normal everyday kind of job
so you need support so this is Kylie
many of you know college smoosh and she
gives me enormous support to help me do
what I do so that I can be here and I
can do these things and this is really
important because if you don't have this
shared vision things are not going to
end well it's enormous ly difficult if
your partner is not on the same
wavelength and they're not supportive of
what you do so I think this is a very
important discussion to have if you want
to go and do even just the little bits
of you know I'm going to spend more time
upstairs on the computer each night or
I'm going to spend more time on the
weekend when I might have been out with
the kids making that decision about what
the right fit is and making sure that it
is actually a shared vision with the
people that you're doing this for thank
you very much
[Applause]
we got a few merits in other questions
yeah stretch so you're saying the shared
vision goes both ways so the a is saying
does Kylie have the same shared vision
as me yes so I mean what I say shared
vision is it's not always just
necessarily that Troy will do a lot of
blogging and writing and all this sort
of thing you know very often it's
visions about how do we want to live
where do we want to live who's going to
be taking the kids to school so you know
it works very well where it makes her
life a lot easier
most of the time Monday to Friday when
I'm around and I can do kids stuff and
then it's much harder than that
obviously when I'm away but this is
stuff we discussed and I think shared
vision is going to mean something
different for everyone but this is why
you got to have the discussion you know
like you got to have this open dialogue
and be transparent with each other and
there's if you don't have that like it's
life it's going to be hard other
questions
all right well I think we are done so
thank you very much for that one and
thanks very much for coming
[Applause]